- white Muslims that's TWA white Muslims
I'm not sure why people call us acts
extraordinarily wasn't looking for Islam
I wasn't looking for religion I was born
into a Christian household I was Church
of England I was raised in a Cheshire
England household we went to Sunday
school we went to church on Sunday
raised as a Roman Catholic I went to
church every Sunday yeah I went to
Catholic schools my uncle was a parish
priest 18 I started asking more
difficult questions and rather than
giving me answers that I understood all
I ever got was that patronizing pat on
the head to say half faith
thank you so you guys this is the three
to two Oreo cookies the conference guys
fabulous job so you guys are from
Britain and how long ago did you accept
Islam for myself sixteen seventeen years
ago myself twenty seven years ago twenty
seven years ago I know it doesn't look
like that could be possible he's go a
bit cherubic face so what was it I mean
we hear all these stereotypes people
thinking you know Islam is something for
the Arabs you know guy with a turban
riding in a desert we got two Brits here
man we got two Brits here what are you
talking about huh what brought you guys
to Islam and for myself personally I I
wasn't looking for Islam I wasn't
looking for religion I was born into a
Christian household out of Church of
England I was raised in a church England
household we went to Sunday school we
went to church on Sunday I was I was a
member of the most inappropriately named
children's group which was the Crusaders
terrible terrible and then kind of never
fell out of love with with the with with
God but stopped going to the church and
stopped went to the groups and found
other things young ladies
alcohol and being raised in a white
Christian household and then many years
later I found myself running a training
course I didn't know anything about
Islam I'd ever met Muslims I didn't know
any Muslims and I found myself with two
Muslims on this course
it was Ramadan I didn't know anything
about Ramadan and I was just talking to
them and engaging with them and they
were saying well this is this is this is
the same you know who Adam is you know
who knows well there are prophets to
Jesus Christ is a fantastic
that guy's a prophet he's absolutely you
know amazing and I was just I was
stunned and I was intrigued and I was
talked and talked and talked and talked
and talked and it answered all the
questions I didn't realize I've been
asking for year after year after year
and I'll handle within six months to a
Shahada and the rest as they say is
history
the reason I asked of you guys were
twins because you did the hosting the
way you guys did it it was like you guys
were synchronized what about yourself
what brought you to this beautiful way
of life okay I was born and raised as a
Roman Catholic I went to church every
Sunday yeah I went to Catholic schools
my uncle was a parish priest so I was
very much in in in the church and
Catholicism loved it I felt very special
as a child growing up it was it was a
wonderful thing when I got to about the
age of 18 I started asking more
difficult questions and rather than
giving me answers that I understood all
I ever got was that patronizing pat on
the head to say have faith son so that
wasn't enough for me that wasn't enough
I needed answers to questions and I
ended up actually walking away from the
institution of the church but I never
walked away from my faith in God so it
was about 10 years later at the age of
tender age of 28 I ended up working in
an office in a town called Bradford in
in in the UK which is a very very large
Muslim population and I got talking to
people and they gave me answers to all
the questions obviously nowadays is a
lot of height a lot of stereotypes a lot
of misconceptions how do you guys deal
with that now when you hear all of this
propaganda and you know out there what
do you usually like to tell people to
kind of you know settle them where
they're not you know in a frenzy okay so
when I when I see I watch Sky News i
watch the BBC news I read the newspapers
I talk to people I hear people talking
about Islam and Muslims and what I see
and hear is nothing to do with this
I love the Islam that's in my art yeah
so I see misconceptions I see
misinterpretations misrepresentations I
see that all the time and what we
decided to do was to put some truth out
there yeah let's just get some grounded
truth out there let's show people what
Islam well we recognize that people tend
to fear what they don't understand so
we've done all we can to help them
understand without colleague here cosa
ty who affectionately refers to us as
his to token ethnic minorities we
created a well we referred to as the two
white Muslims we created a twenty one
video playlist which were placed on
YouTube which was kind of everything you
ever wanted to know about Islam and
Muslim culture but couldn't be bothered
to ask and we just thought we could put
that onto YouTube completely free of
charge people can access it they could
get the information that they needed and
then we thought we could go back to our
real jobs
no didn't quite happen like that because
we kind of got a passion for this now
and so we put that onto YouTube and now
from 21 videos where I think over a
hundred videos and we just pumping
content out it's kind of left right and
center
as you rightly say to quell these
misconceptions to show people actually
Muslims we're just like you but with
faith you know it it's a fantastic
religion it's the perfect legend it's a
beautiful religion normal people people
and we want the same things as you want
yes I want safe streets to grow well my
children too educated the ability to
practice our faith in the way that we
want to practice purpose of life
question that should be on the minds of
everybody
how did Islam answer this question for
you was clear was it lucid when you hear
me say purpose of life Heidi what do you
say to that well we're all on our own
journey and we've got to make it back to
Allah yeah
what we hope is that we make it back to
Allah without becoming toast and it's as
simple as that our purpose in life is to
worship our purpose is to is to submit
to Allah's will and do the things that
allow wants us to do in the way that
we've been shown by our beloved prophet
muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
people had never heard this name before
okay so Allah is a word to describe God
yep the Creator God is the Creator the
creator of all things everything in it
Jesus now okay you abandon Jesus this
was really interesting because one of
the things which I think as a Muslim and
I now fully understand but looking back
maybe had an issue with was this this I
had a fundamental belief in God you know
there's a god there's a creator all of
this didn't happen by chance you know it
came from from one Almighty being but
one Almighty being and to consider
somebody then to be that the son of God
an amazing person yes a wonderful
prophet yes but the son of God that I
now recognize I struggled with and then
when somebody placed the answer in front
of me that well no he's not he's not the
son of God he's amazing he's fantastic
he's wonderful and we love him because
not the son of God it just kind of
reinforced everything and then all these
other names and there were Abraham
David's Moses they all then come into
this timeline of just giving a message
reinforcing a message giving a message
reinforcing a given force reinforce a
message up to the prophet muhammed
sallalahu well if Islam and we just
think I get it Jesus Jesus is named so
many times in the Quran so he yes so you
know have we abandoned Jesus no
probably in fact is now more important
yes many people don't know that it's an
article of faith to believe in love
Jesus ideas messengers ever sent like
Abraham was sent Moses was sent Muhammad
peace and must be upon him was the last
funnel yes sir if you deny one you deny
them all so that's what gets you a
ticket to the help this is very
important so the love that you have for
Jesus now it's clear no Trinity just
worship pure monotheism purpose purpose
of life is clear yeah and a blueprint
for life what else do you have to say
how can people hook up with you guys and
they can go to youtube if you search to
white Muslims that's Twi white Muslims
I'm not sure why people call us that's
extraordinary
and but yes if you got to to ight
Muslims on YouTube to hunt Muslims on
social media you'll be able to find us
but YouTube is the place to go whilst
you're there if you go to our Channel
and subscribe that'll be fantastic it
would really help us get the message out
there and demonstrate the beauty of this
wonderful religion to subscribe and
share subscribe to what wasn't shared to
the journey alight as we're talking
about how we end up here why we here
where we're going it's all answers we
have life from the Creator see you next
time peace be with you Salaam alaikum
Eddie